burbank california home to major
hollywood studios whose employees enjoy
dining and making deals at the local
restaurants
but there's one restaurant that is not
benefiting from this location and it's
in financial hell
it's a neighborhood pizzeria called
sebastian's named after its owner who is
also a part-time actor and who's about
to receive much-needed help from gordon
ramsay
how's everything going i've owned the
restaurant a little over two years i can
cook anything hi that's a sandwich and
my mother's been teaching me since i
could walk so i guess that's my formal
training my ability is endless put it in
front of me and i'll make the dish for
you i'll eat it myself
i think i'm very polite to my staff this
is unbelievable treat him great whoa
very understanding i think
this is filthy this is ridiculous when
he's get upset you might see pants
flying across the kitchen better duck
that's all i have to say ask them do one
damn thing one thing this is why we're
losing money sebastian's you know he's
kind of abrasive at times
sometimes the things he says are like
what it's a big joke to everybody right
big joke they're not paying the bills
people are scared of sebastian this is
ridiculous
i just don't deal with crap i don't do
you make something wrong i've told you
how to make it six times i have no
problem with firing you i have no
problem at all i fired 49 people in the
last year so i'm trying as hard as i can
i'm still getting used to the to the
menu
have you been here before no
it gets exhausting
explain the menu i know
it's overwhelming
i've created a unique menu that nobody
else has we have 23 gourmet flavor
combinations there's 21 gourmet flavor
combinations there's 20 gourmet flavor
combinations wait
pick a flavor combination and then you
add to beef chicken portobello mushroom
or steak
shrimp
wait can i start over so the meat is in
the combination if i saw it i can do it
i mean cause no no it's chicken let me
start over
let me look at it real quick
that's seriously the menu
the majority of the servers are actors
we all know it's really expensive to
live in la and so we need to make money
but sebastian doesn't do a good job at
running sebastians
something going over there i'd say 90 of
the time we are losing money call him
daddy hey mama hey
my wife originally invested probably
about 300 000
what's up buddy what's up mama i'm very
fortunate she does make
good money um
yeah i wish we need checks
i basically control all of the cash the
investment gets
to be resentful
because it's so daunting i did 490
all day
it's hard sometimes
to look at my wife and let her know that
i i don't have the money
if things don't change here at
sebastian's hey guys
i don't see us open longer than six more
months i really don't it's eight o'clock
and uh there's nobody here so
so we're gonna go listen
get out of here
it would be very sad for this place to
close because i love this place
coming in day to day and trying to deal
with that it takes every bit of strength
i have sometimes to really hold on
[Music]
live music wood fire breakfast plasma
tvs
sebastian's finally found it and it's
here right in amongst all these studios
and
on the front out there very tacky
oh my god
yes yeah gordon how are you yes chef
gordon how are you sir i think yourself
pleasure to meet you my wife working
here with chef gordon ramsay it's like
as an actor having uh robert de niro say
you know what i'm gonna help you with
this role
man let me take a seat please and i'll
go to this one here actually okay thank
you
[Music]
do you also do i only serve no but i do
greet and meet every customer that walks
in the door jesus every single customer
whether i come over and just say hello
or i spend 10 minutes sit down and have
a glass of wine with you you sit down
with the customers and drink wine why
not
there's photographs on the menu there's
pictures are these real these
photographs yes they are sir i took
those myself
it looks ghastly
i've always had one simple room yes sir
have you come across a menu with
photographs
get the [ __ ] out of there
our menu concept is very unusual and
unique
i love the variety would you like a
walkthrough of our main concept of the
of the menu
concept we have a concept please over
here is our main concept of the
restaurant what we have is 20 different
combinations of marinades toppings and
seasonings
what you do is you choose one and then
you add it to either chicken portobello
mushroom new york strip or shrimp
angus ribeye prime cut that's cut for
sebastians
you can have one of these combinations
with an entree with chips and gravy on
the side if you'd like with one of our
side salads
[Music]
available at any point in time we have a
half pound angus prime burger i had
actually 20 more
are you serious
yes sir
god i've never heard such a complex menu
in my entire life probably not
okay um okay i'm gonna start with some
um calamari calamari yes um they're
fresh yes it is small portion of
calamari okay um chef gordon questioned
the the quality of the calamari uh my
calamari is fresh
and then from my entree i'd like to have
a new york strip okay you make me a
little uh fresh pizza what type of
feature would you like i'll decide yeah
perfect thank you
lou set me up a small dough please
[Music]
and what's your name sonia sonia
christie nice to meet you
um i'm an actor you're an actress yes i
am what a wrap
do you play with sebastian
because he's an actor oh no okay
and the calamari are they fresh or they
throw you
they are frozen
[Music]
he told me they're fresh
and they're not fresh they're frozen
that confirms two things [ __ ] chef
and a dishonest one
can i get you anything
no a sick bike
he asked me for a sick bag
which i didn't know what to say so i was
like okay
oh god
he said that he wanted a puke back
excellent fantastic i didn't know what
to say though you're not saying it okay
you say yes sir and walk away okay no
problem okay
sebastian
just you could tell in his face that he
wasn't very happy with the comment
i understand the guy's a professional
but to say something like that a sick
bag
[Music]
this is the house speciality i mean yes
yes and what kind of pizza is it what
flavor it's a popeye pizza i'll find yes
hey so i got the chef here chef gordon
ramsay oh yeah yeah he's in the dining
room eating oh hey yeah he uh he thinks
my food is terrible he thinks your food
is terrible yep the waitress asks can i
get you anything else he said yeah a
sick bag
yeah i don't agree with his opinion
i throw him out ah throw him out
yeah
with two wood-burning ovens there i
thought at least they would value to
be in a position to do a stunning pizza
but face is soggy it's all watery
surely to cry but i make a fresh pizza
dough here
sonia
i want you to plate it to him and i want
you to say as sebastian's mother would
say mangia
[Music]
[Music]
it's very difficult to monitor without
my knife and fork i'm sorry i said about
you cleon you've got the part relax okay
it looks like a can of dog food
or an embarrassment to new york strip
steak
[Music]
just chopped and cooked to how
everything's under seasoned enough
canned pet food for today
[Music]
right now okay in my mind i'm hoping
that you can act because you clearly
can't cook the food was shocking
the calamari wasn't even fresh why do
you need to lie to me on a professional
front calamari they're fresh yes it is
they are frozen frozen
i'm not gonna buy top calamari to mix in
a seafood medley we're not a four-star
restaurant everything is cooked to order
even our hamburgers that we just started
making we make fresh pizza dough pizza
don't know that comes in flash frozen
for us i thought pizza was your
speciality i thought that's what this
place was famed for no sir
our men our menu that concept that
baffles you that's what we're famous for
that's why they're cueing up at the door
and you're packing them in right now um
i don't know why my business isn't there
so you're telling me now that those 20
combinations is something that's blown
your customers away unbelievably yeah
blowing them the other end of the
[ __ ] world
i was basically
kicked in the face
to me that shows ignorance and a lack of
respect i truly have no respect for the
man and his awards
they mean nothing to me at this point
okay my pizzas soon will be in
supermarkets
what i would love to franchise this and
have a sebastians all over the world
oh my god just think how that sounds
sebastian's all over the world that
makes me excited you haven't got [ __ ]
one right so far how the [ __ ] can you
think about two
i need some fresh air the guy's gone
this guy is seriously off he's [ __ ]
troy i just won that one i won that one
what on earth is going on in his [ __ ]
up delusional mind whoa yeah i won that
one i want that one
just give me [ __ ] and give it back to me
and it was like uh whatever sebastian
yeah
hello chef um
big boy right now you've won jack
[ __ ] [ __ ] you've got the audacity to
stand there talking to me about
franchise when we can't even get our
pizza right it took everything in me not
to just
freak out i've been here two years it
may not work what have you got to show
what i ever got the show yeah i'll tell
you what i have to show tell me right
pride you're delusional you know what is
your opinion sir a lot of people feel
that way about you
what's successful about out there and
it's still here
that's what makes it successful you just
answered my question
i'll see you later yeah
oh man
[Music]
i think i won that one yes
after a lunch that was not only
disappointing but confusing gordon
returns to observe a dinner
[Music]
good to see service
i'm gonna come on have a beer with you
guys nice yes
we got a lot of directors producers you
know industry people coming in yeah man
holy [ __ ] i'm like how do i know this
guy
the majority of the servers are actors
rappers models
okay i'm a model myself i've gotten a
couple gigs off
working at sebastian's how you doing
brother good to see sebastian's is the
young who's who of hollywood but for
these young actors their biggest
performance happens nightly when they
have to sell sebastian's over
complicated menu
okay let me explain the menu to you it's
a little bit different there's 20
gourmet flavor combinations you decide
if you want chicken portobello mushroom
new york strip it can take up to like 20
minutes because there's so many
different combinations and so many
different options you have on our menu
then you decide if you would like it in
a roll as a sandwich on a bed of lettuce
as a salad or just as an entree okay
i can't even
so much stuff
while the waitresses struggle with the
menu gordon hopes to observe sebastian
leading the kitchen but that is not the
case
kill i'm selling a table uh 100 i got
the siciliano give me the shrimp pizza
with a caprese salad it's coming in 20
seconds i love to cook that's my passion
i love to cook so it's crazy but my
strong point is when we busy
it's frozen
and then you deep fry it
and that goes in a burger bud
is there anything that's ever cooked
homemade
very rare
and what you put in there this is just
the potatoes we're just piping through
and you make fresh sweet potatoes i
believe it comes in frozen yeah
so what do you do to it
we just heat it up we just heat it up so
it's not even powdered match it's
already made in the factory and it comes
in
processed mashed potato
noticing the lack of fresh food
gordon heads to the fridge to confirm
his suspicions and what he finds is a
key reason as to why the restaurant is
failing
well
it's definitely processed
a fridge stocked with pre-packaged
frozen food
nothing's fresh made it's all bought in
sauces yes sir this one's a buy-in yes
yes
yes
i don't think we should be serving as
much of the stuff that we do out of cans
and i think that most of them will serve
out of cans we could probably make that
in-house
where's your
you're bought in though and to gordon's
amazement even the pizza dough is frozen
at this pizzeria and you get them in
frozen yes yum's in frozen i think it's
one of the best frozen doughs i've seen
and uh it's the only way we can right
now to save a dollar
i got to be in there
with the presence of a world-class chef
in the house sebastian decides it's time
to take over in an attempt to impress
chef ramsay masili blue pizza last we
work here okay thank you very much i got
it lou
i can do it i can do it
if i just moved louis through another
station where i thought she'd be uh more
useful at that point and i could kind of
just regain things i have no idea why he
asked me to come over here next pizza
you guys have i want to make i was
really wanting to show gordon that my
ability is endless there's nothing i
can't cook put it in front of me and
i'll make it
i've gone
and to make matters worse this
pizzeria's most important cooking device
is not the pizza ovens
but a microwave
water up
now sebastian's carelessness is
affecting the customers
[Music]
i had a salad go out and it had a hair
in it is it yours it's not my hair
because it's not done
no i don't want to see you eat it
the waitress came over to me and told me
that there was a hair in her salad
what happened i just took a piece of
hair out of my mouth i was eating the
salad a piece of here it was going down
my throat and it
my friend saw me pull it out of my mouth
i'm gonna make you a fresh new salad in
just a few moments i don't think i want
another salad
the salad's gone and so is your pizza
pizza's on us tonight thank you you're
welcome food that was comp there was uh
300 worth of food comp tonight it's we
got that one coming out we [ __ ] up
this one this one's on the house
[ __ ] make some friends
make some friends come on pay attention
with dinner service coming to an end
gordon has many concerns
are you okay
hey i need somebody over here to get
some of these plates going
not the least of them being that the
owner seems to be unconcerned
you'll come back tomorrow i'll be
sitting on the same couch curled up with
a bottle of vodka
talking to myself how are you chef
fine thank you and you i'm doing okay
chilling out with your buddies uh yes i
am he didn't think that that was uh
professional did you need me chef i need
two minutes with you on your own
okay i'm gonna get inside and uh
work you guys gonna hang out for a
little bit yeah
i was kind of upset at chef gordon at
that point
um i felt like it was being a little
unreasonable
let's just have a little taste together
[Music]
what does that taste for you
it's not great it's a little dry it's
cut the [ __ ] end off squeeze it into
the container and send it
a lot of stuff isn't homemade 95 percent
of the stuff is brought in uh okay i i
was going to go with 80 this [ __ ] is the
most disgusting [ __ ]
sporting crap i've ever tasted in my
entire life
it's almost more important for me to let
this go out
at half its quality and go out and make
sure that the guests are happy and meet
the guests and talk to them
you're happy
to be a fake chef honor
no
because i don't believe it on a fake
show
it's a franchisable
concept why are you so [ __ ] obsessed
with becoming famous with a franchise
why can't you just have a restaurant and
cook your ass off and get customers in
here for the love of what you're doing i
was hoping that this would be my
launching
pad for my name how
that's not crooked
if you are convinced in your mind right
that what you're doing is gonna work
you're beyond reach you know that
really
[ __ ] me
up next gone the old menu is gone with
the wind there's a confusion but a new
menu i don't see any uniqueness has
sebastian seeing red
and later
we're done get the camera out of here he
just changed like dr jekyll
gordon gives sebastian the painful truth
never ever ever ever
met
someone
i believe in as little as you
in a town known for its movies tonight's
dinner service is a major flop
the nominees for the most confused
restaurant in hollywood
is sebastian's
[Music]
sebastians
and sebastians
[Music]
and your most famous word tonight was
not any form of delegation organizing
insight
it's on me
comp that one i'll take care of that
bill serve that to there you're running
a business not a freebie drive by pick
up and go home
we shouldn't be saying that
at ten to nine in the middle of a bloody
busy night
what do we comp in terms of
dollars probably close to 300
300 bucks yeah [ __ ]
i don't know what to say working with
gordon is going to be a challenge i felt
like he was being a little unreasonable
here's the thing
what needs to happen here
big change
we will have
a new menu
are you all right
[Music]
it's day two and after yesterday's
eye-opening observations it's time for
gordon to get through to this stubborn
chef
with pre-packaged and frozen food
turning customers off
gordon gets the staff headed in a new
direction to take advantage of the pizza
ovens which up until now have been used
just for show and not for cooking
sebastian's yes yes needs to become
known for one thing and one thing only
fresh pizzas what are those two things
there pizza ovens this place can become
so popular for homemade fresh
wood-burning pizza i'm not making the
money and it's quite expensive to really
start using fresh dough again
guys come here
have you or you or you ever
tossed
a pizza dough no no
not here
all of you yeah are now gonna become
great tossers i've got two
phenomenal
expert tossers here now gentlemen come
in please come and say hello gordon
brought in a couple of guys to show us
how to be pizza tossers and everything
it is just like going to ben and hunters
and watching them chop your food and
cook it right at the table i think this
looks wonderful in front of customers if
i was sat here in my family watching you
do this listen
now yeah i want you to become the
perfect tosser
lou you have a go yes
cue
let's go guys all of us yeah i'm up for
a challenge and willing to try something
new
the only thing i hate about that whole
thing is i have to get rid of my nails
but other than that i love the fresh
pizza dough
okay guys let's go
at this point in the game one of two
things has to happen i have to accept
what he says and go with it
or ask him to leave
it's day three while gordon took the day
to get the staff focused on fresh food
and using the brick pizza ovens his
design team worked overnight to
transform the restaurant good morning
guys ladies
i'm excited to see the changes such as
the court guys ready yes yes
okay don't drop the baby yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
first minute i walked in this space it
was ridiculous
it feels new and fresh yes
it's just overwhelming the way the place
looks
[Music]
new chairs new couches new linen little
bar there to serve your cocktails from
this is great this is so gorgeous
you start to see just a nice vibrant
clean look
wow it looks new
sebastian the first time i've heard you
lost the words yes
he's speechless ah
it's absolutely beautiful
lou happy
very yes
good this is huge it's bigger than big i
just cannot describe how happy and
overwhelmed i am now
one more thing okay we got rid of the
frozen pizza dough because from this day
off you're now going to be making your
own dough
[Music]
that is the best of the best it is an
extraordinary piece of equipment lose
come over my daddy
you wanted fresh dough in here is that
right rumor has it yeah now you can make
fresh dough to your heart yeah i was
overwhelmed i was looking at that mixer
it was
phenomenal now you've really got your
work cut out my darling you know that
okay good
this is the start yeah of sebastian's
turning around there's no excuse
anywhere from decor to wood burning oven
to vibrant attitude from the staff the
real work starts tonight there's no
excuse
although sebastian craves success he has
been resistant to change and now he's
about to face his biggest fear first
thing we'll do is play to our strengths
okay kind of noticed that it was holding
two menus one being mine and one being
the change that i think i was most
afraid of and uh that really made me
nervous
what i'm gonna confirm now
is that the confusion has gone gone yeah
is a confusion
gone is sebastian's 20 ingredient mix
and match flavor menu with pre-processed
frozen food it looks like a can of dog
food
and in its place our made to order items
using fresh and homemade ingredients
just have a look let me read you through
the menu first okay
pizzas all cooked to order on our very
own wood burning oven a margarita a
salami a vegetarian and then the entrees
grilled new york steak and a wood
burning oven cooked chicken there's
nothing quite like this currently going
on in this neighborhood you have got an
amazing chance to succeed here if you
keep it simple i like the new menu it's
simple the fresh product and the fresh
dough that's a big thing for me take
away the intimidation sebastian play to
your strengths
use what you've got
when gordon showed us the new menu i
think it was a bit overwhelming for
sebastian's head are you upset there's
no photos on there
there's uh photographs on the menu
there's pictures of the food i took
those myself
no no the photos uh isn't the thing that
i'm concerned of it's just uh it's it's
it's the change i was scared of are you
worried about the size of the menu
now the size isn't the concern it's uh
i don't see any uniqueness
you're not gonna now ask me to turn
around and say what you gave me in terms
of pizza was unique
i've created a unique menu that nobody
else has and chef gordon said i quote
him i've never seen a menu like this
before so i'm assuming that it's quite
unique to him also stop trying to be too
clever
don't try to be too smart
if you are
you know anxious about 20 combinations
it's 20 times confusing i thought that
there'd be more compromise with my menu
i didn't expect it to be just completely
gone i love that menu
you've tried for two and a half years
and it hasn't worked
that's the end of that chapter
with the academy awards falling on the
same night as the relaunch gordon
decides that this coincidence should be
taken advantage of and is rolling out
the red carpet for an oscar night party
and sebastian's is fully booked we're
gonna kick ass and everything's gonna be
a whole lot better tonight i like to see
this place rock
tonight expect a lot of chaos but it
should be fun here
i'm fighting right now still inside
about that menu it's driving me crazy
right now in my head hey we're serving
yeah we're serving you know 100 people
in 20 minutes with the kitchen hard at
work with last minute preparations
sebastian is still brooding over
gordon's overhaul of his menu
it means a big joke to everybody right
this place is a mess nobody wants to
clean
okay why uh sebastian where is he send
everybody home and do this [ __ ] myself
[Music]
where's sebastian
it's office and he's all fritz
[Music]
this place is a mess and the waiters
they can't even clean i got to come in
and vacuum the rugs what is that about
one minute he can be the happy-go-lucky
sebastian who put this chair on the
floor this is what i'm talking about
and then we wonder why we're losing
business
[Music]
it's oscar night and more importantly
relaunch night at sebastian's
i'm very excited and we're just going to
have so much fun with the new everything
wherever you want
i'm really excited to prove to chef
gordon that we can actually do something
right
and although there's excitement in the
air sebastian is feeling one thing more
than anything else where's sebastian
pressure this is ridiculous
[Music]
okay two seconds
um control it whether you're running the
pizza side or whether on the grill as
those orders come in push them out get
on top of it and make sure that everyone
is not shouting across each other one
person controlling it yes okay any
questions no sir good thank you let's go
already the restaurant is buzzing about
the new menu
[Music]
and the first wave of orders is now
hitting the kitchen i got some
margaritas in okay
good
tonight the pizzas are selling great
these shrimp nickies are going like
crazy light crates you know what the
margarita the salmon on the small
an hour into service and the new
simplified menu is enabling the kitchen
to run smoothly and the orders are
getting out in good
[Music]
keep in mind time the dough is all
homemade enjoy i hope you like it and
gordon's new made-to-order entrees are
impressing the customers
the shrimp tastes good
the night is going very well a lot of
people are enjoying the new food because
they think it's really fresh
much better
much much better
but instead of being happy sebastian is
still disturbed over the menu change
that's good
[Music]
hey
look at that yeah and think frozen
mashed potatoes
no comparison
i want to try to go back to all those 20
flavor combinations there's a lot of
uniqueness with the menu i was using
whether he thought it was good food or
bad food it was unique
sebastian still doesn't fully support
gordon's mandate for freshness
this is gone this is gone
you gotta pull them tickets and before
the night is over the microwave is back
in action
[Music]
make me a primavera off the new menu or
the old menu now the old menu
all right
a primavera an antipasti and another
pittsburgh
okay i need to know what sebastian did
here because this is a mess
unfortunately sebastian's reversion to
his old menu has caused confusion in the
kitchen i need this for 35.
was that 35 what you just sent out right
there no this is table three and this no
i think the one that's the same erica
i need that sandwich
i
i can only tell you from a server
standpoint it was almost like a domino
effect once one thing started happening
then another than another
that's sebastian i can tell you right
now we're gonna need help over here
[Applause]
we started using old menu and there was
so much confusion in the kitchen
so
you know yeah
i love the new menu but i the original
concept of sebastian's with the 20
flavor combinations i'll never lose that
no [ __ ] why are we serving the old
men you bumped me
looks like something for [ __ ] dog's
dinner
no [ __ ] way
no no no
no i just wanted to know what happened
if i wasn't here
are you serious do you think no i'm
asking yeah i've been asking don't start
this go [ __ ] cold here we go cue
action drama [ __ ] me
welcome guys i hope you enjoy your pizza
oh yeah
it appears as though sebastian's ego is
getting in the way of his potential
success and gordon's had enough
sebastian i knew i ended word with you
first right my man
he can talk to me any way he wants but
when it comes down to it i don't know
what i'm doing
okay
when i first arrived here we got off to
a shaky start sure think about it oh
yeah
and then we kept our heads down and we
got through it together yesterday and we
made some really exciting changes
the menus changed the staff have changed
yes
mate there's one thing that hasn't
changed in this establishment
and that's
you sebastian
i'm 40 years of age and i've gone to a
lot of restaurants
but i've never ever ever ever met
someone
i believe in as little as you
i think that you will go back
to your
sloppy
shortcut
five out of ten frozen weights
good luck
unbelievable
and [ __ ] believable [ __ ] useless
you [ __ ] kidding me
you [ __ ] kidding me right now
[Music]
honestly i haven't seen sebastian this
emotional
sebastian just got real out he just
changed like dr jekyll and just to hide
[Music]
that's pissed on his bonfire [ __ ]
arrogant [ __ ] that [ __ ]
we're done get the [ __ ] camera out of
here
[Music]
jeff gordon
[Music]
jeff gordon where the [ __ ] are you
where are you okay you come into my
restaurant yes i'm just so [ __ ]
disappointed you're gonna calm down stop
pointing your finger at me
are we gonna speak like men you're gonna
speak to me like a man
didn't listen you're not listening to
what i'm saying did you just hear what
i've just told i'm stepping away from
you because i don't want to be too close
you ungrateful you have no idea
you have no i [ __ ] idea joker [ __ ]
[ __ ] you that's it yeah it is it you're
very disappointed i can [ __ ] [ __ ]
performers tonight are you [ __ ]
kidding me your whole act is a [ __ ]
joke anything else your whole act is a
[ __ ] joke you're a phony you
shouldn't run like that run like what
am i supposed to be scared now sebastian
come on give me a break i busted my ass
in there you tell me
are you kidding me
are you kidding me let me just tell you
something you're telling me nothing i'm
done i'm done you get your bit in yes
loser
i'm telling you one last time you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] while sebastian lets
off steam outside
inside the kitchen has come to a halt
gordon has put an enormous amount of
effort into sebastian's he has also been
impressed by the staff's willingness to
change hello lovely don't they huh
are they going out now
wow
it's hard to hear
that what you've done is a failure
come on guys salmon and chicken away
yeah roasted vegetables let's go it's uh
it's true some of the stuff he says
maybe i was a little twisted with my
ideas and my goals if you look at the
numbers
then i guess it looks like i'm feeling
okay ready happy little slice of lemon
knife please it's a slap of reality and
i know he's right
it's not easy to accept
but i guess before you grow you got to
accept it
keep them in there get them nicer yeah
it's my family my my kids
makes you want to work harder
let's go what's next
can you talk to me boy
shrimp yeah good
i don't have the degree
they go to school
i know i've got talent i'm a damn good
cook
i'm not giving up
i'll get there i'll get there
[Music]
everyone's just kind of looking around
and we didn't know what was going to
happen
i was speechless i couldn't even tell
you how worried i was because i'm
supposed to be this big bad guy right
i could feel him watching me i felt like
he would say
what are you gonna do about your kitchen
it's falling apart i'm like you're right
i got i got i got to fix this how are we
looking
are we are we back on top now
where are you staying on top yeah
not confused no no
[Music]
sebastian just came in and he was ready
to go give me a large crostini i got you
i'm sick
once things started going smoothly
sebastian seems to be a lot more
optimistic get a little excited in here
i appreciate the enthusiasm the fact
that i've got a one in a million
opportunity here i'd be a fool not to
accept it
send it out let's go
seaman's gone yes so we love him let's
go point around
i need us out on the fly
with sebastian back in the saddle the
staff rallies together and turns the
kitchen around
service has stepped up food is going out
on time and most importantly the
customers are happy
[Music]
bloody well done
you took on the changes well
you all adapted
change is a challenge it's hard but i
think it'll be worth it in the long run
it's everything that we've worked for
lou
your enthusiasm is infectious you know
that coming from chef gordon made me
feel really good to know that that he
saw that in me so that was cool
andre
happy
very yes yes yeah we started off slow
but hey we didn't crumble did we
we got more adjusted to the menu and
things started working a lot more
smoothly for us
tomorrow
it starts again
yes
well done yes
[Music]
very good
[Music]
[Applause]
i respected chef when he came in
my opinion changed of him when i met him
and he's reiterated to me
i don't have to agree with his methods
the result is what it is
as i leave sebastians i have a lot of
mixed feelings i really know this
russian can be a big success but i also
feel sebastian has very little interest
in sticking to the new plan
you